[Music]
Hello again, this is doctors
Miguel Garza from the Monclova surgery,
this time I want to present a
3D video about the gastrointestinal industry,
the
minimally invasive procedure we use to
diagnose various diseases such
as gastritis, reflux, hiatal hernia,
bleeding from the digestive tract  and gastrointestinal ulcers
we hope this video will be useful for
you
an endoscopy of the
upper gastrointestinal tract also
called gastroduodenal esophagus
copy or axis of is a procedure
that allows the doctor to visualize the
mucosal walls of the upper part of the
gastrointestinal tract this includes the
esophagus stomach and  duodenum
upper endoscopy is used to
assess symptoms of
persistent upper abdominal pain nausea
vomiting bleeding or difficulty
swallowing
can accurately detect
inflammation infection tumors
ulcers and other problems that may
occur during the process  The procedure is done
using an endoscope which is a
long thin flexible tube with a
tiny video camera light on the
end the camera transmits the image to
a monitor before you undergo the
endoscopy an IV will be placed
and you will be offered
pain medication and a sedative
your blood pressure your
pulse your blood oxygen level will be checked
during the procedure your doctor will
apply a local anesthetic to your throat
with a spray bottle or
ask you to gargle with an anesthetic to
numb the area  you will be asked to
lie on your left side
a support mouthpiece will be placed in your
mouth in some cases
additional oxygen will be given through
a nasal cannula make two
upper copies that are
uncomplicated take 10 to 20
minutes
your doctor will carefully insert  the
endoscope through the mouth and then
slowly and carefully move it up the esophagus
until it reaches the  stomach
and eventually the duodenum you should
feel no pain while this is happening the
doctor can periodically introduce
a small amount of air to
flatten the mucosal walls and improve
visibility if the doctor wants to obtain a
tissue sample for analysis
later it can be done with the endoscope
a biopsy  it will help distinguish between
cancerous and benign tissues
it is also used to detect
helicobacter pylori the bacteria that
can cause ulcers to form
the doctor may also use the
endoscope to treat a problem
such as a bleeding ulcer or
widening a narrowing of the esophagus
or the stomach after the procedure
will be monitored until
the effects of the medicine wear off it is possible
that your throat hurts and it feels
a little swollen you will have to have
someone to take you home later
and remember that for questions and
comments we are  on the lookout for
any of our  these forms of
contact and we hope to attend
[Music]